just like in exponential growth in decay
do you remember all the time you had to
show that this like frequently in the
first part of a question was
please show me that this satisfies the
differential equation because that's
this is what makes simple harmonic sorry
this is what makes natural grid the
decay natural growth okay in the same
way this is what makes simple harmonic
motion simple harmonic motion so what
they're asking for in this best part is
differentiate to find your velocity
function and your acceleration function
and show that basically this for
particular values of n a particular
values a bit so let's just quickly
rehearse this plasma hi okay I'm going
to go they've mixed together be in mixed
up not under white bit I'm gonna go with
consistency differentiate once which
gives you good yeah that that's what I
was about to say before me as soon as
they get to the punch I differentiate
again which gives me
okay now do you know it they've given
you the result right you know where
you're going to go so I think the burden
is on us to make sure we show every
single step so I'm going to take out a
factor off what factors should I take
out negative price quit once you do that
here you got well put your highness
right so you're gonna factor out that
for on-site right and then what you get
left me if you can see that's my ex
there's my displacement function right
because it's full it's for one of the
the owner hires disappeared because I
want to pop up high once and then of
second PI then 4 to 4 PI there's no play
there's no full PI there to make it for
my square here's a four and it sends it
to that one
yes okay hurry we're fine puppies
amplitude period central pushin okay
amplitude when is amplitude come from
where is it defiant amplitude is just a
coefficient of one Everett sine cosine
whatever wave function you've got in
your displacement function okay so
therefore the amplitude I'll just read
as for on pi but by the way we have
units units a big right to us
they're meters right okay go
they could just as easily of Austin and
I'm not sure if they ask it later on
no they don't they could just say if
evenly have asked for the extremes of
motion which your answer would be very
very slightly different what would you
say if you ask for the extremes of
version you'd say for apply and negative
for my baby on two extremes because it's
doing what were the other two things as
well
period center motion okay so period
equals alright how do I get period out
of this okay so you can either remember
alright the period of any trig function
is just going to be two pi on in
wherever ends your coefficient of that
if you find that a bit confusing because
people often will do n on 2pi or they
don't know which to divide I just speak
back two simple examples get back to
first principles so everyone knows what
the period this is okay so when you
introduce something like this and you've
seen this one hundred thousand times
right tell me in comparison to the
original what this looks like it's it is
squashed it's more frequent right see
you like okay I've got from 2 pi K off
to PI so clearly under vine through by
this in fact a nice way to think about
it is this is sine 1 X right
whatever that coefficient is is how many
cycles of your full thing that you get
into cut right so for example if I saw a
sign of you know whatever a hundred X
that means I've got a hundred full
cycles for not to do play right so how
many full cycles do I have yeah from
from Lotter to PI I've got PI cycles
that's a bit weird because this is
trying to get us away from having pie in
elevators right so I'm going to go back
to how to get that number is 2 pi on and
which is PI ok so the period to second
does that make sense
I should say seconds as well
um I would teach answer with the unit
yeah questions me just okay and lastly
the center of mission we can just take
this right
the center is x equals 0 okay it's the
origin yep